and tears I cried flat woman go to flood
you big river and I'm gonna sit right
here on July 5 Johnny Cash known by
generations of music fans as the man in
black may soon be immortalized in marble
in our nation's capital each u.s. state
gets two representatives in the National
Statuary Hall inside the Capitol
building this month Arkansas governor
ASA Hutchinson signed a bill that will
swap out his state statues will be cash
who was born in Kingsland Arkansas and
grew up in the town of dice his statue
will be joined by one of civil rights
leader Daisy Bates mentor to the nine
black children who integrated Little
Rock Central High School in 1957 cash
and Bates will replace two controversial
nineteenth-century figures Uriah Milton
Rose a lawyer who sided with the
Confederacy and former Arkansas governor
and Senator James P Clark who reportedly
held segregationist views Arkansas still
has to raise funds for the new statutes
after the old ones are removed 11 others
with Confederate ties will remain in
Statuary Hall including general robert e
lee representing Virginia and Jefferson
Davis the president of the Confederate
States sent here from Mississippi and
the two statues that are being removed
in there for over a hundred years so the
state feels it is time now for those to
go a lot of statue changes going on Kate
Smith statue in Philadelphia may be
coming down so there's a running female
people wonder if it's if you should talk
about the history or if you should just
remove them